chances de se faire interpeller.
L'institut de Nicolet, devant ce
phénomène, a décidé de lancer
une étude.
- Mettez ça sur YouTube,
s'il vous plaît.
- Oui, ça va aller sur YouTube.
- Être policier en 2021, c'est
être constamment sous la loupe.
- Je finis de parler.
- Intersection de...
- Donnez vos papiers.
- Je vais vous donner mes
papiers. Mais est-ce que vous
pouvez m'écouter?
- Je vais vous dire bien
franchement, je n'en arrête
plus, des gens racisés.
- Tasse-toi! Tasse-toi,
je vais te "taser"!
- On a peur de se faire accuser
de profilage racial.
- Mets ton bras dans le dos!
- Monsieur...
- Il y a personne qui veut
briser sa carrière
pour une intervention.
- Ces déclarations à coeurs
ouverts proviennent de quatre
policiers toujours en fonction
au Service de police de la Ville
de Montréal: deux sont blancs,
deux autres sont issus
de minorités visibles.
BENOIT (prénom fictif),
policier, SPVM
- C'est rendu difficile.
On a beau vouloir travailler
et faire la job qu'on nous a
appris à faire, mais on n'est
plus capables de la faire
comme on le devrait.
- Radio-Canada s'est engagé
à protéger leur identité pour
éviter de possibles représailles
de leur employeur parce qu'ils
n'ont pas l'autorisation
du SPVM pour parler.
Ce qu'ils racontent,
c'est le phénomène désengagement
policier, surnommé depolicing
aux États-Unis, qui gagnerait
la police de Montréal :
une forme de refus du policier
de remplir son devoir envers
la population dans certaines
situations. Son inaction
volontaire face à la commission
d'un crime lui servirait
à éviter des ennuis,
pour ne pas subir le tribunal
populaire des réseaux sociaux
ou des médias. Et même
si la loi lui permet d'agir.
ANNIE GENDRON, psychologue,
École nationale de police du Qc
- Ça a vraiment été un phénomène
beaucoup plus en émergence suite
aux événements de Ferguson,
qui sont survenus en 2014, et
plus récemment, les événements
de Georges Floyd.
- Le phénomène préoccupe l'École
nationale de police du Québec
au point d'avoir demandé une
étude pour mesurer son ampleur
au Québec. Mais les policiers
rencontrés n'ont nullement
besoin d'avoir les premières
conclusions attendues cet été.
MIKE (prénom fictif),
policier, SPVM
- On est tout le temps filmés.
Et si quelque chose arrive, on
nous ramène toujours les cas qui
se passent aux États-Unis. On va
tenter de faire des liens. On ne
sait jamais comment un événement
va être présenté publiquement.
C'est de la pression.
- Dans les groupes privés
de policiers du SPVM sur les
réseaux sociaux, les discussions
sur le désengagement policier
se sont multipliées
en quelques mois.
- Le terrain peut glisser
pour une intervention banale.
Il s'agit qu'une ou deux caméras
filment, qu'une séquence
seulement soit montrée et là,
ce n'est plus du tout
la même intervention. Pis là,
tout le monde parle de toi.
- Mike, qui fait partie
des minorités visibles
qui ne représentent que 13 %
des effectifs policiers,
affirme ressentir la crainte
de l'opinion public.
- En ce moment, je rentre
chez moi, j'enlève mon uniforme,
personne me connaît.
Il suffit d'un incident et là,
tout le monde sait où j'habite.
Il y a des conséquences
très graves sur le plan
psychologique. Tout le monde
va voir ça sur les réseaux
sociaux. Tout est déformé.
Ta face est mise partout.
Que tu aies raison ou non,
tu es humilié publiquement.
- Un avis partagé par Benoit,
qui est affecté à un poste
de quartier différent.
- Moi, présentement, j'aime
bien mieux tourner à gauche
en voiture s'il y a quelque
chose est en train
de se passer à droite.
Je vais vous dire bien
franchement, je n'en arrête
plus, des gens racisés.
Je ne veux plus m'exposer
à des risques.
- Le désengagement policier
est causé par un ensemble
de facteurs. À la police
de Montréal, la nouvelle
politique d'interpellation
plus sévère qu'avant
est difficile à accepter
pour certains policiers.
Ils ont l'impression d'avoir
été blâmés inutilement.
Pourtant, un rapport sur
le profilage racial a révélé
qu'une personne noire avait
cinq fois plus de risques
d'être interpellée par rapport
à une personne blanche.
ALEXANE (prénom fictif),
policière, SPVM
- La direction du SPVM nous a
imposé des règles plus sévères,
comme si on ne travaillait pas
bien, ce qui est faux. Au lieu
de cibler les policiers qui ont
besoin d'encadrement pour
leur inculquer une pratique
professionnelle, ça a donné
plutôt des arguments à des gens
qui militent contre nous.
- Les activistes, ce sont
les groupes de pression, comme
le collectif pour définancer
la police, qui a annulé
une entrevue planifiée.
Pour sa part, le porte-parole
de Black Lives Matter est venu
à notre rencontre. Celui
qui représente le mouvement,
qui affirme défendre
les droits civiques des groupes
minoritaires, ne croit pas
un seul mot des témoignages
recueillis par Radio-Canada.
VAN HARRY, porte-parole,
Black Lives Matter Montréal
- En ce moment, quand
on me parle de... veulent pas
intervenir, je me demande :
où ça, en fait?. Parce qu'au
contraire, on voit que
les interventions sont accrues
au nom de la pandémie,
au nom de... Et c'est toujours
les mêmes personnes qui sont
interpellées davantage :
les personnes itinérantes,
les personnes autochtones,
les personnes noires,
les personnes racisées.
J'appelle ça une légende
urbaine.
- Impossible de connaître
la tendance des interpellations
des dernières années. Le Service
des communications du SPVM a
refusé de nous répondre et nous
a suggéré de faire une demande
d'accès à l'information.
- Si un policier parle
à une personne, je veux dire,
qu'il se fasse filmer ou pas,
s'il a rien à se reprocher,
ça change rien, en fait.
- Pour ce militant, les vidéos
de citoyens ne disparaîtront
pas de sitôt.
- Les gens ont peur de la
police. Donc, leur seul outil
en ce moment, c'est de sortir
les caméras, parce que c'est
la seule preuve qu'ils peuvent
avoir. Je veux dire,
sincèrement, en ce moment,
s'il y a pas de caméras,
c'est la... c'est un policier
contre notre parole.
- Selon les policiers
rencontrés, moins d'engagement
policier signifie moins de
prévention du crime.
MAXIME (prénom fictif),
policier, SPVM
- Les gangs de rue, ils ne se
déplacent pas en autobus
ou en taxi. On doit intercepter
des voitures pour enquêter.
Pour leur mettre de la pression,
c'est du travail qui se fait
en interpellant.
- La pression est plus forte que
jamais sur le SPVM pour contrer
la circulation d'armes à feu
illégales, rappelle ce sergent
à la retraite.
STÉPHANE WALL, ancien formateur
en usage de la force, SPVM
- Ce qui est bien important pour
les citoyens, c'est le sentiment
de sécurité. Donc, si je prends
un quartier chaud comme
Montréal-Nord présentement,
bien, les mères de famille
là-bas demandent de l'aide
pour leurs fils et leurs jeunes
qui sont impliqués dans
le phénomène de gangs de rue.
- La criminologue Maria Mourani
craint que certains quartiers
montréalais ne perdent
leur sentiment de sécurité.
MARIA MOURANI, criminologue
spécialiste du crime organisé
- Il y a un un impact partout.
Encore pire dans les quartiers
qui sont plus chauds. Si en plus
de ça, vous ajoutez des
policiers qui osent pas trop
intervenir dans ces coins-là,
dans ces rues-là, dans ces
quartiers-là, parce qu'ils ont
peur de se faire traiter
de racistes, bien,
un plus un, ça fait deux.
- La spécialiste du crime
organisé invite donc
la population à une réflexion.
- Pour pouvoir avoir une police
professionnelle et forte,
qui fait un travail, autant
préventif qu'en réaction,
il faut la supporter.
Ce qui ne veut pas dire
que la police ne doit pas
se remettre en question.
MAXIME (prénom fictif),
policier, SPVM
- On ne peut pas constamment
taper sur la tête des policiers
et penser qu'il n'y aura pas
de conséquences. On n'a pas
juste un uniforme. On fait
partie de la même société.